so i'd like to thank you very much for
that introduction
and i'd like to really thank you
particularly for the honor of giving the
phil
sharp lecture in neural circuits
um you know there's sort of things that
change and things that stay the same
over time
and i've known phil sharp
since he was considerably younger than i
am now
and some things about phil have and
looking at these two pictures
actually um it's remarkable how much
some things have not
changed he's really the same person he's
he's a little blonder than he was then
but then so am i and um
and he's and actually at the time
something that that
some people here might remember but most
probably don't is that both of us had
quite substantial southern accents which
are now largely
uh buried after years and
outside of our homes but there are
certain things that
even while and there are things that
change that i think
are more surprising like i think at that
time no one would have guessed that phil
sharp would have been
head of an institute for brain research
and yet what what what you would have
predicted and what hasn't changed is
that you would have predicted that if
you did it he would do a great job at it
because phil is someone who takes things
really seriously
and the scientific motto has always been
you know if you aren't going to do it
right don't do it at all
and that sort of perspective because
phil was right down the hall for me my
first few years of graduate school when
i was in the weinberg lab
was something that really permeated his
own lab his environment our joint group
leadings
and his own research over the years and
i think that that
is the lesson of mit the high standards
of mit are exemplified in
bill's attitude towards science and um
if i can
feel a little bit like i'm sharing in
that by giving that lecture then
then i'll take it thank you i should say
phil was always trying to keep the
weinberg people out of his lab
he thought we were we were trouble but
uh but at the same time i can remember
one of the first important results i had
going to show it to phil because i
wanted him to see that
that something had worked because he was
that kind of a scientist that he was
everyone's colleague
not just for his own lab
so um i'm going to talk about
how we're thinking about the way that
the c elegans wiring diagram
generates behavior and the thing that
drew me to c elegans as an experimental
system
at the beginning of my post up was a
publication of a complete wiring diagram
of the c elegans nervous system
uh connectome if you will of the
complete set of neurons here every each
and every neuron
is illustrated here as well as the
connections and light gray between them
from work of john white and his
colleagues
and you know the the thing that's
alluring about this is the idea that you
have the entire nervous system of an
animal in front of you
and that you should be able ultimately
to understand everything that animal
does
based on the properties of those neurons
and their interactions with one another
and this is a project that has actually
made a great deal of progress
in many labs over the time since then so
for example
for most of the neurons at this point in
this diagram
we can say something about what kinds of
biological functions they have that
there will be some sort of a genetic
piece of evidence or or evidence from an
ablation or some other manipulation
that tells you this neuron is important
for this particular kind of motion
for example but there are other aspects
of the nervous system that are
still quite difficult to explain from
this wiring diagram
and really what it is that's going on in
the interactions between them has been
fundamentally a mystery even though the
individual components
have have gained a lot of have gained a
lot of understanding
and it's that question of the
interactions across the nervous system
that i'm going to focus on today i
should say that this is going to be a
talk
in honor of its title completely about
neural circuits
i'm not going to talk much i'm not going
to talk at all i think about molecules
even though people in my lab are still
very interested in how molecules affect
the nervous system and i would like
to particularly point you toward the
fact that stephen flavell a postdoc
in my lab will be here next week giving
a talk about
the roles of neuromodulators and shaping
behavior in c elegans
but i'm going to try and address this
question of how this nervous system
gives rise to behavior
and i'm going to start by sort of
setting up
the thinking about the nervous system
that i think actually permeates a great
deal of the field which
is that the the nervous system is wired
and set up to generate responses to
environmental stimuli
i read a lot of grants that start
something about how i want to understand
a behavior from sensory input to motor
output
and that implies some kind of a fixed
pathway that gives rise to a behavior
that implies a real relationship between
here as
rene descartes illustrated some sort of
a
nerve fiber here in the toe that detects
the heat of the fire
goes up to the brain and then generates
a signal that will tell you to remove
your foot from the fire
descarte was the first to sort of
illustrate this concept of a central
location
in which sensory information was
processed to give rise to behavior
now when you work on c elegans and you
have in front of you the wiring diagram
it's very alluring to think of that as
the sort of set of instructions for
behaviors like this that when we look at
that wiring diagram we should be able to
follow a set of arrows from one point to
another and
lead those directly to things like the
the behavior of the organism
and there's certainly a level at which
that's true there are in fact many
things that we know about the behavior
of c
elegans that we can formulate or attempt
to formulate in these terms
so the behaviors that my lab studies
most and the one i'll focus on today
are behaviors that have to do with
whether the animal is attracted to
or repelled by different kinds of odors
in its environment
sea elegance has a very rich sense of
smell it can detect
hundreds probably thousands of different
molecules and it has strong innate
behaviors
associated with those so small molecules
like diacetyl shown there on the left
are made by bacterial food and they're
highly attractive if you put a bunch of
worms down on a plate
come back an hour later virtually all of
them will have approached that odor
conversely this long chain molecule here
seems to be toxic to the animals and
they avoid it just as assertively as
they
approach the diacetyl so these are
innate behaviors they're reliably found
in each individual
and um we've learned quite a bit about
how these molecules are detected
so for example when piali sengupta was a
postdoctoral fellow in my lab
she identified the receptor molecule
that detects
diazepa a g-protein-coupled receptor
called odor 10
and that serves as the founding member
together with the c elegans genome which
was emerging at the time
for the olfactory receptor family of c
elegans
or families i should say there are about
2 000 orphan g
protein coupled receptors in the worm
genome
that are in divergent families and
expressed in olfactory neurons so we
think that these are
literally ten percent of the genes in
the worm are being used to solve the
problem of detecting environmental
stimuli
now the way that the worm detects the
stimuli is to express these different
receptor genes on sensory neurons found
in its head
illustrated there in red and in blue
and um
and the um we know that for example the
neuron that normally detects diacetyl is
this blue neuron here
and if diacetyl is no longer detected by
this neuron through the loss of this
receptor the animal is no longer
attracted to this odor
the repulsive odor is detected by a
neuron right next to it
so um when emily trummel was a graduate
student in the lab she did an experiment
in which she moved the odor 10 receptor
from its normal home to a neuron that
normally senses repellents
and what she found was that these
transgenic animals were no longer
attracted to diaz appeal
but they could detect it and in fact
they were repelled showing a behavior
appropriate for a different olfactory
neuron
the one in which it was now expressed
and so this too
really fits the idea of an innate odor
preference and it even gives you a sense
that that odor preference is encoded all
the way out to the periphery
where the attractive or repulsive
valence of an odor is directly encoded
by the sensory neuron that detects a
receptor
this idea of innate preferences seems to
apply
um to the sensory systems of more
complex animals as well
um a nice example comes from the work of
charles zucker and nick reba
looking at mammalian taste sensation and
their work on characterizing
the taste cells of the mammalian tongue
shows that
different taste cells express different
receptors either for
attractive or repulsive pastings
and that merely activating those neurons
in the periphery is sufficient to give
you either an acceptance or a rejection
behavior
by rodents so here we also have an
example of an innate preference that
seems to be encoded all the way out to
the periphery
that leads to an innate and reliable
behavioral response
now this idea is very useful in looking
at peripheral sensory neurons
but as a way of thinking about behavior
it actually
over emphasizes i think an aspect of
behavior which is it's sort of
reliability and reproducibility
because in fact one of the most obvious
features of behavior when you look at it
in any organization is its variability
so i my own personal uh favorite example
of this is uh
inspired by michael fee's work and by
other work in
the field of songbirds so songbirds
generate learn and produce a song
that they enable to attract their mates
and
it turns out that this song is normally
very reliable
but both during learning and later in
life this song can be more variable or
less variable
not just because the animal is incapable
of singing a better song but because
variability is actively
injected into the song and the idea here
is the following if you're trying to
generate a motor behavior and you're
trying to do that for example by trial
and error
if you aren't trying to do different
things you will not explore the
different kinds of mechanisms
that will label you to make a proper
song and so practicing
and varying the outcome will lead to
better outcomes
either during learning or actually later
in life here
an example the variability of a songbird
song is actually influenced
not only during learning but actually in
a mature songbird based on whether he's
singing to a female
or just practicing on his own and a
specific brain region
called l man is actively required
to generate this variability into a song
circuit
it's not just a sub threshold
performance variability is something
that is being actively generated
and by a particular brain region and
placed in the motor pathway
so this idea of variability as an
important feature of learning
and of certain behaviors also finds
finds incarnation in certain kinds of
behaviors that incorporate variability
as an essential component of how they
work
and it turns out that chemotaxis the
simple attraction to odor
while it is completely or largely
predictable
on a whole animal level is a behavior
that is variable or
unpredictable on an instant to instant
level
and this we can see if we just look at
animals trying to respond to an odor we
see them take various different paths to
get there it's not as so they simply
turn directly into the odor and perform
properly
and work originally by sean lockery's
lab developed a theoretical and
experimental
framework for this that showed that in
fact the animals
approach odor in part using a naturally
variable strategy
a strategy called the biased random want
and the strategy of this which was first
worked out for bacterial chemotaxis by
howard berg and his colleagues at
harvard university
is that the animal moves through the
environment
not detecting the absolute direction of
odor but simply paying attention to
whether odor
is increasing or decreasing if
conditions are getting better and odor
is increasing the animal will continue
to move in the direction it's currently
moving
but if it's it but if the conditions are
not getting better the animal will
change direct direction and try a new
direction for some period of time
to see if conditions will get better if
it moves in this new direction
so what this means is that the animal
approaches the odor
through a path that's not predictable
and furthermore the turns are random
they're made in random directions
and varying in time although the rate of
turns is predictable
the time that any particular turn is
generated is not
but this general kind of strategy which
is sort of if
if it's working keep doing it if it's
not working do something else
it's actually very useful in many
aspects of life
and it's useful to the worm in
particular and there's actually
theory foraging theory that suggests
that it's actually one of the best ways
to track to an odor in an environment
that's noisy in an environment that you
can't control
in any case there's sort of a general
question that this this raises which is
what there are here are probabilities of
turns how do you change something in the
environment
a signal about odor into a probability
into something that will happen or not
happen
what's happening to flip the coin to
cause something to occur at a particular
time
so studying these behaviors um
studies of these behaviors and of
related behaviors in my lab and a
variety of other labs
um including arabi samuels and yin zhang
uh
at harvard have identified a set of
neurons
downstream of olfactory neurons that are
important in controlling this behavior
so this is sort of a first order circuit
for this probabilistic turning behavior
downstream of an olfactory neuron called
awc which is the main olfactory neuron
that directs a lot of these biased
random walk behaviors
so the awc neuron and this is actually i
want to make a couple of points about
this the first
is that this is the way that most people
draw the worm wiring diagram
it's a hierarchical feed forward kind of
model
where information starts with a sensory
nerve on the triangle at the top
and ends with motor output pathways
which would be circles at the bottom
that the sensory neuron actually
converges with other sensory inputs
on a series of what are thought of as
integrating interneurons for sensory
information and those are those four red
blue cells the ai cells
and these cells here are coordinated
regulators of different kinds of turning
behavior
so they can stimulate the rates of
different kinds of terms or inhibit them
based on whichever one they are and they
can actually affect the rates of several
different kinds of terms
in in concert so they affect direct
reversals they affect the kind of u-turn
the worm makes called an omega bend
or omega turn and they can also affect
the amplitude of the sine wave that the
anomaly makes as it's moving along
which will help it curve toward or away
from an odor
so this circuit here is what we would
like at some level to understand when we
try to understand
when the animal is responding to odor
how is information flowing from the
sensory neuron to the motor output
that is sort of a question that that is
raised by this wiring diagram
in particular and by wiring diagrams in
general
so the first so in order to address this
we wanted to develop a really well
controlled situation where we could
reliably deliver the same odor stimulus
to animals over and over again
and ascertain their behaviors so the
problem with the good thing about
letting an animal move freely in a
gradient
is that it's a natural behavior the bad
thing is that each animal is determining
its own experience
as it moves and so you don't know
necessarily what the important
parameters are
and so um in the lab dirk albrecht when
he was a postdoc spent some time
developing methods that would allow us
to
deliver stimuli to animals in a very
reliable and reproducible pattern
and then observe their behaviors and
this is i would say something that we
sort of take a little bit from the
monkey psychophysicists actually who
were the first to really point out the
importance of bringing quantitative
methods to neuroscience in studying
behavior so we've moved that model way
down to the worm level
and we do that by allowing the animals
to move within little microfluidic
devices
and in these microfluidic devices we can
deliver different kinds of stimuli
and this movie here is going to show you
a number of c elegans
moving around in a microfluidic device
while different kinds of substances are
flowed past them
so um these animals are moving around
you can see that sometimes they change
orientation
sometimes they move around and this dark
color here is the appearance of an
attractive odor this uh isolated alcohol
and the light color is when it was taken
away and when the isoline alcohol
appears the animals move in long
straight lines
and when it's taken away they turn and
so
that's the odor appears the animals move
in long lines they suppress turning
the odor disappears the animals start
turning again so this
is the behavior pattern that is
predicted by the via strand and walk
model
and in this case it's a behavior pattern
that you can generate reliably over and
over again
to look at the animal's response not
just in a qualitative way but in a
quantitative
ask what happens and so using these
methods
followed by automated analysis of the
behavior we track the animals and
automatically score all these different
kinds of reorientations
we can look at the responses of the
animal to the odor and here you're
looking at the responses of about 250
animals
to a 15-minute sequence of odor addition
and removal on various schedules
and each line is a single animal each
color trace represents a particular
behavioral pattern
and what you can see here is that the
animals do suppress turns when odors are
present
and they do enhance turning when odor is
removed but that
these responses are quantitative and not
qualitative
the rate of turning never goes down to
zero and the rate of turning never goes
up to a hundred percent
and you can manipulate this experiment
in many ways and you always get that
same result
but the bottom of the curve is at about
ten percent turning and the top of the
car is about eighty percent turning
there's always a probability of failure
and a probability of success
so you can ask so the question we wanted
to ask is well why is that
why isn't this response completely
reliable we have this animal every
animal has 302 neurons
why are they performing sometimes and
not others and so one
idea could be that some animals don't
develop properly or that there's
something wrong with them
or that there's something about the
number of trials or about alternating
trials
so one of the things about this kind of
a quantitative assay is that you can
score the same animal over and over
again on trial after trial and ask
whether it responds or not
and here's an experiment in which dirk
did that categorizing different kinds of
responses to the outer stimulus
24 trials 23 animals and what you can
see in this checkerboard is
that all of the animals responded
sometimes and not other times
all of the animals are showing a
probabilistic behavior pattern
so a single animal's behavior varies
from trial to trial
and these trials are just a minute apart
so this poses a question for us we have
an olfactory neuron
we have a reversal behavior we know that
that there's a neuron
long known in c elegans to be important
in reversal behavior called the backward
command neuron
and we have a reversal behavior why is
it that sometimes you get a reversal and
sometimes you don't
and actually the shortest direct path
from the olfactory neuron to the
backward command neuron is a
through path there's actually one direct
synapse even from the sensory neuron
there are a lot of
indirect synapses through this neuron
aiv and then there are a lot of other
indirect routes to the command neuron as
well you can see all of these arrows
indicating that these guys are heavily
connected
and the neuron i want you to focus on
i think your mic might be off and i
don't want anybody else to miss your
talk about that
there you go
sorry i'm not starting over
okay so there are many through paths
from the
odor to the behavior and um
but the ones i'm going to [ __ ] you can
see that you can actually these neurons
are heavily connected there are many
ways of getting from point to point
and i'm just really going to focus on
these neurons here and we selected them
because they represent the largest
number of synapses when you just sort of
count through the connectome and say
these look like they might be important
and they were supported by experimental
evidence
so just starting from the beginning um
the first
question in order to answer that
question is that we want to be able to
look at neuronal variability and
behavioral variability at the same time
and this is another version of the
microfluidic device that dirk developed
this one here
this one here is one that enables us to
simultaneously monitor calcium imaging
in this case in the awc neuron which is
that little spot there by the star
and when the awc neuron so this animal
can be moved
can be moved freely while we deliver
odor to it we can monitor the presence
of odor the fluorescence of the signal
and the behavior of the animal
simultaneously
and what this animal did this little
peak here which corresponds to the
removal of odor
was associated with that little
reorientation maneuver there in red
so we can do this experiment not just
once but many times
so for example you can take a single
animal and 80 times in a row expose it
to exactly the same stimulus
look at the behavior and look at the
response to the neuron and what you see
is that the neuron
here in these heat maps the brighter
colors the yellower colors indicates a
response
to odor actually it's odor removal that
seems to happen pretty reliably
but the interesting question is not just
whether this neuron responds reliably
but how on a trial to trial level
and not on average it responds to
different kinds of stimuli
and so we can actually do that by taking
those movies that i told you
and separating them out based on what
behavior the animal did in a particular
trial
grouping together the responses in which
the animals did a large reorientation
which is in red
a small reorientation which is in black
or simply fail to respond to the odor at
all which is in gray
and then we can line up the different
responses of the olfactory neuron in all
those trials and average them
and what you can see is that there is
really no
change between the response of the
olfactory neuron depending on what the
animal did
in fact these three curves are
absolutely superimposable
so the olfactory neuron knew in every
trial
that the odor was added and removed but
the animal failed to respond in a subset
of trials
so somewhere other than the olfactory
neuron there's a change
in behavior now conversely you can go to
the very end of this pathway and look at
the so-called backward command neuron
you can look at its activity in freely
moving animals and what you find is that
it's not
perhaps quite as reliable but that
ninety percent of the time if the animal
is making a reversal this neuron is
increasing in activity
and 90 percent of the time if the animal
is terminating a reverse syllabus neuron
is dropping
and this result has been seen by a
number of different groups
so we now have we can sort of simplify
the circuit down to the following
elements we have a sensory neuron
we have the backward that responds to
odor the backward command neurons that
synchronize with reversals how do we get
the uncoupling between them
so the first thing i should say is that
when i said the sensory neuron was
active that was
um what i was reporting to you was the
change in fluorescence in the cell body
based on genetically encoded calcium
indicators
and that is not necessarily a great
indicator of the neuron's potential
so the first thing we wanted to ask
which is actually an idea that's very
prominent
in the synaptic plasticity field is
whether the release probability of this
neuron was in some way being regulated
there's a lot of ideas about unreliable
synapses or regulation
of pre-synaptic release and to get at
those donovan ventimiglia a graduate
student in the lab
developed a set of reagents that he
could use to in a cell type specific way
monitor the synapses of the awc neuron
and these are
cell type specific gfp based reagents
one of them is a calcium sensor that is
not generically expressed everywhere in
the cell body
but rather specifically localized to the
synapse by fusing it to
the synaptic vesicle protein synaptic
dryrin
and the other one developed originally
by geromisinbuck and then subsequently
modified by rob edwards
is a ph sensitive green fluorescent
protein
that is fused to the vesicular glutamate
transporter
it labels glutamate containing synaptic
vesicles
and when they fuse with the plasma
membrane and the ph changes from low to
high
this molecule becomes fluorescent so we
can use this as a direct measure of
glutamate vesicle exocytosis
this sensory neuron is glutamatergic
and so when donovan so donovan looked at
those two in the awc olfactory neurons
to ask
first of all how does synaptic calcium
relate to cell body calcium
and second how do excellent endocytosis
relate to the signals we see in the cell
body and the answer is
that as far as we can tell these neurons
do respond reliably
at their synapses and in terms of
synaptic vesicle release
now the reliable gets an asterisk there
because these animals could not move
freely in order to measure these much
smaller signals we had to physically
immobilize them
but we do see very similar signals
in this in the axon as we see in the
cell body except that they're somewhat
faster
actually and the um signatures of
vesicle release show exactly the
patterns of endocytosis and exocytosis
that would be predicted to be associated
with a suppression of vesicle release
when calcium is low
and enhancement of calci uh vesicle
release when calcium is high
so we think based on this that probably
the sensory neuron
is signaling at the synapse and
releasing glutamate
so now let's go downstream to the next
level of neurons
so we can look at the direct
postsynaptic target of awc this is the
neuron aib
and then we can look through to the
backward command neuron ava
now here on the left we can see the
average responses that these neurons
have to odor and what you can see
is that i'm going to focus on the
response to odor
onset it's stronger
behaviorally and easier to monitor and
what you can see is that awc has a very
sharp
very reliable response you see a
suppression of responses in the aib
neuron
and you see a suppression of responses
in the ava neuron as well
so at some level information is flowing
through this pathway
and you can see that they're nice sort
of small error bars around this signal
which make you think that everything is
going well
but this is actually the problem with
looking at average responses because
remember we're not really interested in
the average response here we're
interested in the variability
we're interested in why sometimes the
behavior happens and sometimes it
doesn't
and that becomes more interesting if you
look at these individual traces
and the heat maps here actually indicate
to you that the average responses shown
there on the left
have small error bars just because you
keep expanding the numbers you can make
any
error bar really small so in fact
there's a lot of variability
that and specifically if you look at the
calcium responses in the sensory neuron
every single time you add odor it just
crashes down to the baseline and stays
there but these neurons here have a lot
of neurons
have a lot of examples that just don't
change activity at
all at the individual level so we
decided to think about what that meant a
little more and to look a little more
carefully at those traces
and now i'm going to show you what the
single traces look like
just directly monitoring calcium instead
of as a heat map
and the first thing that struck us about
them when we looked at them
which we again missed by averaging is
that in fact when we look at the inner
neurons and this is different from the
sensory neurons
we see that they have highly bistable
behavior
they have either high or low activity
but they spend very little time in
between they seem to be jumping back and
forth between high and low calcium
states
and we see this sort of characteristic
by stability
in all three of the inner neurons
so now let's reanalyze the three
interneurons and i actually showed you
just the first one to begin with but now
we're going to look at all three of them
individually and we're going to
categorize each of the neurons
based on whether it's in a low state or
a high state at the beginning of the
experiment
and then ask what happened when you
added odor and what you can see is that
the main effect of odor addition which
happens at the same time in each trial
is to induce transitions from high
states to low states
the neuron is already in a low state
nothing happens
and but the neuron only transitions from
the high to a low state a set percentage
at the time
so there's a group of animals in which
that happens right on the line and then
a group in which it doesn't
and the number in each case varies
slightly from neuron to neuron
and we can quantify this reliability by
organizing these traces
and basically the result is that if we
look at the sensory neuron 100 of the
time we see an odor response
and if we look at the first downstream
neuron we only see a response 60 percent
of the time
and if we get down to the backward
command neuron we see a response about
45 percent of the time
and based on the conditions we're using
here that's actually a pretty good match
to how well this neuron would be
responding how well this animal would be
responding to
the odor behaviorally so we're seeing a
drop
in the transmission of this signal
across these synapses
so what's happening to make the cynic
signal drop
first i'm going to tell you one other
thing the next thing that we looked at
so andrew gordas a postdoc in the lab
developed ways of recording from several
of these neurons simultaneously
looking at all three of the neurons in
this network downstream of the sensory
neuron
and when he looked at these three
neurons simultaneously he found
as he had seen originally that they were
bistable they tend to be either high or
low and to jump between those states
but it's not just that they all tend to
jump between those states they tend to
jump between those states at the same
time
these neurons are highly correlated with
one another even the jitter in these
responses as well as the overall level
seems to be strongly related across time
and these are just a few representative
traces looking over different times
these are actually in buffer there's no
odor present it's a spontaneous movement
of these neurons between active and
inactive states
and andrew looked at these states for a
large number of different animals
adding up to many hours of monitoring
neural activity and what he found
is that if you imagine that there are
three neurons each of which can have two
different states there are eight
possible activity states within the
network and only
three of those eight activity states
were basically represented
at all within the activity of these
neurons within the error of our
measurement noise
those could be either all three of the
neurons off all three of the neurons
on or just this one neuron downstream of
the sensory neuron on the aib neuron
the other five states as far as we could
tell just didn't happen under these
recording conditions
so this is giving us a clue that these
neurons are actually acting together in
some sort of a collective process
and it's also giving us another way of
categorizing the data i was showing you
right i said that we could look at the
response of a neuron based on whether it
was on or off
we can also look at a contingent
response we can ask we can look at the
response of this neuron
based on whether the other neurons are
on and off
and when andrea did that first when he
looked at all three of the neurons
together
when all three of them were on actually
they tended
to respond together as shown in those
individual traces
and when all three of them were on
basically between 40 and 50 percent of
the time
they responded to odor so this is an
unreliable response to odor
indicated by the top guys responding the
bottom guy's not
but when only the aib neuron was on when
odor was added
it responded completely reliably to odor
every time we added the odor this neuron
gave a response
and plummeted down to its lowest
baseline level
so this suggests to us that we have a
way
of categorizing the responses we can
start to predict something about the
network
by knowing more than just the state of
one neuron at the time that the signal
arrives
so that's a correlation it's very
interesting we saw similar correlations
with certain kinds of mutants that would
alter the activity in this network but
we wanted to go about testing directly
whether
that activity pattern was actually
responsible for something about the
variability we saw on the network
and to do that we used a chemogenetic
reagent developed by naveen pocola in
the lab
which took it takes advantage of the
fact that c elegans does not use
histamine as a neurotransmitter
and so we can create a false
neurotransmitter a dread like molecule
for those of you working in mammals
by making it sensitive to a transmitter
that does not produce
and the thing that's nice about
expressing the histamine gated chloride
channel in a neuron and silencing it
is that you can feed the animal's
histamine they take it up and within a
couple of minutes you see
a very strong response in whatever
neuron that you want to see
we also see really nice silencing
electrophysiologically that's
that's rapidly reversible
so we can use the histamine-gated
chloride channel
in this context to silence
individual neurons in the network and
ask whether if we artificially
create the activity state that we're
interested in can we then recreate the
response to odor that we would have seen
in that activity state
is it sufficient and so what andrew did
was to
again record simultaneously from the
three different neurons
and then in this case silence these two
neurons ram and ada
using the histamine-gated chloride
channel and you can see that within five
minutes they're completely silent
and they remain silent this is an intact
animal
but the aib neuron is still going on and
off with its normal pattern so it hasn't
been
apparently affected too much by this and
but when we add odor we now see
a really highly reliable response in aib
to odor so silencing the downstream
neurons has made aib
from an unreliable to a reliable
autoresponding neuron
so that suggests that this activity
state is really instructive to the
network
one of the fun things about having a
genetic reagent is that we can not only
look at the normal activity states but
we can generate those other activity
states that never exist in nature
where any one of the neurons is silent
for example or any two of the neurons
are silent
and so by doing those andrew asked what
other neurons were important
in generating reliability in the aib
otoresponse
and what he found was that if he
silenced this
intermediate neuron here rim the
aib response as shown here becomes
completely reliable
but even more interesting than that at
that point
the ava response also becomes completely
reliable
so he switched this network now from a
state where this neuron would have
responded rather unreliably to odor
to one in which it responds every time
it's as though rem is a distraction
from whatever the animal is trying to do
and um he can change this experiment
around a little bit by instead of
silencing rem
with the histamine gated channel
silencing the rn
chemical synapses with tetanus toxin and
the reason for doing that is you can do
that and still maintain looking at the
activity of all three of the neurons
and all three of the neurons still work
under those conditions but if our and
chemical synapses are silent
all three of them are now almost
completely reliable the whole network
has been switched into a network now
where all these neurons respond to outer
onset every time odor appears
if they're in the if they're on the
upstate
so what do we think this means we think
that these results
mean just one way of interpreting this
is that we know that the um
aib neuron is immediately downstream of
the sensory neurons
and it's always been regarded as sort of
a collecting sensory interneuron
but what these results suggest is that
this neuron is receiving information
feedback
from further downstream systems and the
neurons that it's receiving information
from
are neurons that are more directly
involved in
motor outputs i didn't emphasize this
but ram is not only between aib
and ava ram is itself a motor neuron
that affects several muscles so the fact
that rem activity can affect aib
activity indicates that we're pushing
information
from the motor circuit back up into the
sensory integrating neurons
so basically what the data show are that
the sensory neuron responds reliably to
odors
that this second neuron can respond
either to odor
or to the network state as expressed by
the activity of these downstream neurons
and then you reach the ava neuron that's
active during every reversal
the key element that couples aib to ada
and the reversal state is ram or that
uncouples it
these experiments are all based on just
monitoring neural activity
the next question you should be asking
yourself is whether these neurons are
actually active in the same way
in the natural behaviors that the animal
shows and whether this pattern of
activity that we're observing
is actually relevant to the way that the
animal to
to what the animal would be doing in its
behavioral decisions
so the first thing we did so the
experiments where we imaged all neurons
simultaneously again had to be done in
immobilized animals it's just sort of a
limit of where we are with respect to
the optics and the indicators and what
we can do
but we can look at each of these neurons
individually in free-moving animals
and we can monitor as i showed you for
the sensory neuron the activity of the
neuron
and the behavior of the animal and so
what we see when we do that for each of
these four neurons in isolation
is that in fact the circuit is both a
sensory circuit
and a motor circuit in freely moving
animals why do i say that if we look at
the animals being exposed to odor
stimuli shown here at the top
we can see a strong effect in the
sensory neuron
and we can see a kind of wobbly variable
response in each of the three downstream
interneurons that moves in the same
direction
not so different from the average
response i showed you when we looked at
the calcium
traces when but if we look at
spontaneous behavior what we see is that
these three neurons
are also active at the same time with
actually very small error bars in the
context of spontaneous behavioral
transitions
so all three of these neurons become
active when the animal is
transitioning to a reversal all three of
these neurons become less active when
the animal is transitioning from
reversal to forward movement
now we really believe that these are
spontaneous behavioral states that these
represent the coupled motor state
in part because if we look at the
sensory neuron we do not see those
correlations
the sensory neuron is maintaining its
own in this case
rather low level of activity while these
neurons are going back and forth
synchronously with the behavior of the
animal
second question is this pattern of
activity and reliability
something important in what the animal
does so to do that we took some of the
same manipulations that we had done to
manipulate
activity in neural imaging and asked
whether those affected the behavior of
the animal
so in this experiment what we did was to
silence the ram neurons in animals that
were moving in odor
and we took them we measured their
behavior under conditions in which the
odor response is variable
like those conditions that i showed you
earlier in this case the addition
of odor transitions animals toward
moving forward about 50 percent of the
animals move forward
and if we silence the rem neuron the
animals now move forward
much more reliably they actually become
more sensitive to odor
through this neuron being removed and
that's the prediction that's made by the
circuitry and the imaging responses we
saw
so this seems to indicate that this
neuron is responsible both
for reliability of neuronal responses
and reliability of behavioral responses
so just to conclude what do we think
this means we think that we've been
thinking about this particular sensory
circuit
as as having a as sort of propagating
information
forward from the sensory neurons to
various kinds of motor pathways
what our results suggest is that
actually it doesn't just matter what the
sensory input is for what a behavior is
going to be
what matters is the state of the circuit
when sensory information
arrives that the motor circuits are
spontaneously moving back and forth
between different activity states
some of those states are responsive to
sensory inputs and some of them are not
now i've um we i
i've told you about three of those
neurons in this
element in this circuit motif um
i'm bringing this slide back up though
to remind you that these three neurons
are just
three out of a fairly large number of
neurons even within this sub motif of
the 302 neurons in the worms nervous
system
so the first thing i want to say about
this is that i don't think there's any
reason to think that the manipulations
we did are sort of a unique
solution to this problem we seem to have
two
kinds of inputs a sensory and a motor
input that can drive the circuit
but some of these other neurons might
also be capable of tipping that in
that particular input from one side or
the other and in fact i think it's very
likely that this entire network of
neuron is involved in making decisions
i think the most likely way to think
about what
this result might mean is that the
sensory neurons are in fact
accurately reporting sensory information
that different kinds of motor neurons
are capable of generating particular
motor outputs
which again they tend to do in a
dedicated way but the level in between
is basically one network that's in that
it's an interconnected network
and that the decisions are being made
collectively by the neurons at that
level
and one of the reasons i think that is
the kinds of results i showed you and
some other results from the lab
and another reason i think that is based
on some experiments recently published
by alipasha baziri and manuel zimmer's
labs
in which they simultaneously monitor the
activity of about 100 neurons in the
brain of a worm
in this case not necessarily linked to
behavior and again just sort of watching
spontaneously what the activity of those
neurons were doing
and what they observed when they did
that was that
there were quite a few neurons within
that that had activity that was
obviously correlated with each other
that there were neurons that were
becoming active at the same time and
turning off at the same time
and while they don't know what most of
those neurons were
at least two of them were the two ava
neurons the backward command neurons
and there was reason to think that at
least one of the other ones was aib
so this network probably consists not
just of the couple of neurons i showed
you
not just of the six neurons represented
by those three pairs
but probably something more like 30
neurons probably 10 percent of the
nervous system or possibly even more
tends to become active and inactive in a
correlated way
and the other thing that emerges from
their analysis
again this is still very early but i
think it's extremely thought-provoking
for us
is that there are other um there are
other groups of neurons that tend to
become active together
that the neurons are not acting
independently of one another they're not
302 independent units of information in
this
in this diagram but rather smaller sets
of neurons
with different kinds of correlations and
anti-correlations to each other
so i think there may be a menu of
collective activity states that the
animal is choosing between
and that these in turn are determining
the sensitivity to sensory inputs
so um i so just to
sort of generalize this idea and bring
it out a little more
to other nervous systems one of the
so one of the things i told you
basically is that what we think of
as a sensory circuit is sensitive to
motor activity and circuit states of the
animal
and in fact if you look at the
literature
in different animals in ranging from
flies to humans
there's evidence that different kinds of
general slowly acting circuit states
affect the processing of sensory
information including sensory detection
and sensory gain
and so i've used three examples of that
to show examples of how
what we think of is really a sensory
system is affected by
the motor the motor state of the animal
on a rapid
um second to second level the first is
from my colleague
gabby maymon looking at visually
responsive neurons in the fly optic flow
sensing system
showing that the gain of their response
is much greater when the fly is flying
than when the fly is resting
so the sensory response is is affected
by the motor response
at pretty much the same time as this
paper came out there's a paper from
chris neil and michael stryker showing
exactly the same thing
in orientation selective neurons in v1
visual cortex in the mouse
but the gain of these responses was
affected by the spontaneous movement of
the animal the animal spontaneously
starts moving
and the gain of its visual responses
increases so there are motor signals in
visual cortex and in fact later to be a
sponhofer's lab showed that even if the
mouse is in complete darkness
you can see the motor signals moving in
and out of visual cortex
and sort of spontaneous activity
and finally an example from humans fmri
studies of humans performing visual
detection tasks
shows that in association with these
visual detection tasks
there's sort of large slow changes of
activity and visual cortex
here on the order of 10 seconds and
these changes do not
affect whether these changes are not
affected by whether the target is
present or absent
but they predict how whether the human
will correctly perceive the target
that these large-scale changes in
activity are actually helping
to affect your perception of weak visual
stimuli so the idea that these sensory
systems are absorbing information from
other states of the animal
i think is one with broad broad
broad analogies
and this really brings me back to the
bird which is where i started
um in some ways but you know to me one
of the big lessons
of the birdsong system is that sensory
circuits are also motor circuits
that when you look at the same circuit
from different perspectives
in particular the song producing system
of the songbird if you look at that
system
in anesthetized or sleeping bird it's
completely driven by auditory stimuli
it really is tuned to the bird's own
song and it responds to the
birds-on-song
when the bird is awake it's a motor
system it responds only to motor inputs
and to the drive of the animal's
behavior
so i think it's uh recognizing that
these systems are not separate but
actually that the brain is performing
collective and collaborative tasks in
which the different systems are
interrelated with one another
i think is is one we can learn from the
bird and think about in other settings
and finally um one of the things that
that
i think that this points out is the
importance of different things that are
going on in the nervous system on
different time scales
so when we've been studying sensory
neurons in general or in fact
in many different kinds of studies in
neuroscience we always focus on the
first
the fastest the very rapid processing of
information
and you know in these cases we're often
looking at things that happen in
milliseconds or even microseconds as we
look at the action of channels or of
synapses
certainly when we look at sensory
responses and we look at their timing
we're looking in very small time domains
but these
um this information is being
superimposed on slower endogenous
activity states of the nervous system
that the kind of circuit states which um
or
attractor-like states that we see in
collective groups of neurons are
evolving on slower time
scales perhaps 10 times slower than the
time scales of sensory inputs
and can yet change this time scale of
sensory inputs
and other kinds of variability for
example can be generated by
neuromodulators in association with
motivational states on even slower time
scales time scales of minutes to hours
so these will be shaping the response to
sensory time scales
in a dynamic and flexible way even
before sort of long-term effects like
plasticity or development or learning
take place
and so with that i will just um thank
you and show you some of the people in
the lab who did this work
i was talking mostly about work done to
try to understand variability
done by andrew gordis here in the bowtie
my lab is always extremely well dressed
and and the work on looking directly at
synapses awc synapses in their
reliability was done by donovan
ventimiglia a graduate
student living pocola a postdoc here in
the thai
the dna thai developed some of the
reagents like the histamine-gated
chloride channel
dirk albrecht in johannes lars the two
blondes in the back row there
develop the methods for simultaneous
calcium imaging and behavior
and just hidden here a little bit is
steve lavell who will be here next week
to tell you about neuromodulation
thank you